&gt;&gt; Slope intercept form is a great way to write the equation of a line, but it
isn't the only way. In the previous question, one of the equations was 2x plus
3y equals 6. This is an example of equation written in standard form. Standard
form has the variables on one side of the equation with coefficients, and then
other side is usually constant. In standard form, we actually usually list the x
variable first, followed by the y term. I want to talk more about this equation,
specifically the slope of this line. But first, let's think back to the previous
lesson and see if you remember how to calculate the x and y intercepts. So fill
in the missing numbers. Where does the x intercept occur and where does the y
intercept occur?